winter is coming not only am I starting
to forget who the good guys are I'm
starting to wonder if there's any good
guys left Game of Thrones Season 5
episode 9 the dance of drag this one I'm
a bit up and down on it's not a complete
drop off from an excellent episode that
we got last time but there's still some
pretty uneven stuff here i will start
with what i love i love what goes on in
marine i'm obviously this is the spoiler
free i'm not going to talk about what it
is but pretty much everything that
happens there i love i loved what
happens the way it's done the way it
shown it's just really incredibly well
done was very rewarding to watch and in
a lot of ways what went on there
elevated the episode as a whole some of
the other stuff what went on in Dorne
was fine it felt sort of obligatory but
it involved fairly fun interactions
amongst the characters involved so
that's you know it tastes the curse off
it a little bit we got some stuff going
on and Bravo so we pick up with Aria
again that I've used the term spinning
wheels wheel spinning a lot that one
feels a little bit like is in that it
was a slightly interesting direction
I'll be interested to see where it goes
from there but we didn't get the forward
step that we thought we were gonna get
and now we've got this other one and
it's it's okay it's just it's just
taking us like divergent Ronis not
grabbing me by doing that now that's the
good too all right stuff there's one
aspect of the story that I really really
didn't like and unfortunately I also saw
it coming so it wasn't a huge shock I
was just really annoyed that the show
did it now of course I can't say what it
is but I think I can describe why it's a
problem without getting into spoilers
there's a conflict that's been built up
recently between the two factions which
is a fairly standard thing in Game of
Thrones now in any given sort of clash
of two sides we may not have the one
that we're inherently yeah I love them
but generally between the two there's a
better there's a worse you know you have
some degree of investment in terms of
who you would rather see end up being
the victor in the upcoming conflict now
going into this episode I had a pretty
clear version
this is the side that's worse this is
the site I don't want to get the upper
hand now what happened in this episode
with the side that I had been favoring
in this upcoming conflict they did
something that now I hate that that's by
design they do something that really
dirties their hands now I don't have a
problem inherently with either sort of
good or maybe conflicted characters you
know doing something that's very morally
compromising that can make for
incredibly compelling storytelling the
reason it's such a problem in this
specific instance is I now don't care
about the upcoming conflict that's being
built towards because as far as I'm
concerned I just want both sides to die
so now i have no investment in that
conflict anymore and that i think is a
problem just a basic fundamental
storytelling problem I've lost all
investment I don't care who wins and who
loses actually I would rather they just
both completely wipe each other out and
i feel like i don't even really want to
see it anymore so in trying to add sort
of more moral grayness and complications
they just end up taking the stakes out
of the thing for me i mean overall it
was still good i'm sorry that that's
largely because what was good and it was
so good that it kind of buoyed
everything about I mean the stuff that I
didn't like I also really didn't like so
maybe its kind of even keel at the end
of it but it was not the the massive
step down from the last episode which
was just what I was dreading cuz the
previous episode was so good I'm like oh
god there's two more episodes to go that
means there's two more episodes where
they can lose everything they just came
back from me and they didn't lose it all
but they did you know with this one
thing kind of did I guess that's about
it so let me ask you this is sort of a
general premise what do you find sort of
more compelling as story arc do you find
the story of a good person or someone
who's trying to do the right thing going
down a dark path more compelling or
someone who has maybe been on a darker
row before but or been more out for
themselves starting to become more self
lising in go on a path of redemption
which of those two sorts of scenarios do
you find more compelling as a general
rule whatever it is drop something down
in the comments and let's talk about it
until next time this council is
adjourned